- You have already 150?
From 4,000 views?
That's gonna be a lot
of fucking applications.
- [DRock] A lot of creators.
- Everybody's a fucking creator.
- [DRock] It's 132, I lied.
- What?
- I'm just finish that
everyone's a creator,
I was waiting for your
like, to make the joke,
that even you're a creator,
even though you're not.
But you were in your own zone.
See?
Everyone thinks they're a fucking creator.
♫ We're unstoppable.
I'm on my way to a talk
to Chase, my client,
Vaynermedia's client.
Looking forward to that.
:28 in the morning,
Wednesday, hope you guys are
all doing super well.
Trying to figure out
our cadence with the new
edit style.
Reading all your feedback
the last few days.
Not a bunch of sleep, so
kind of slugging along
this morning, a little out of it.
But we'll get it goin' in a minute here.
The game fires me up.
(heavy metal noise)
- You're welcome.
- You know, for me, the mentoring of Tyler
is super important.
He's my assistant, my lead assistant.
We have two now with Z, you've
seen her running around.
- Happy Friday, everyone.
- And I think a lot of you
who are running businesses
don't realize that the
conversations and the mentorship
on a day-to-day basis,
teaching them the long game,
the short game, what
your wants and needs are,
what you see in them,
how they can be better,
is a huge vulnerability.
You guys just want
everybody to click right in
to your expectations without
you putting in the work.
A lot of you have bad puppies and dogs
because you didn't spend the time up front
to put them in the right position.
A lot of you have kids
that aren't reaching their
expectations of you because
you took for granted
those early five or six years.
I mean, if you want
somebody to be successful
in the long term, you
have to disproportionately
put up work in the front
to make them successful.
And that's what I'm doing
with Tyler, and ironically
that's what I was teaching
him to do when somebody
new joins the team, and it's
something I've taught you,
DRock, that's something
that you've struggled with.
We've all struggled with that.
Like, you know, when you add
somebody new, your thought is,
this is gonna be easier
now, I can do more, I can do
better, I can do faster.
The problem is, for the
first 60, 90, 100 days,
you get slower because
you have to put it all
into them.
You have to answer all those questions,
you have to fix all their misses,
and so, and then what if
they don't even work out?
What if after 120 days,
it's not the right person?
You oftentimes don't
make the move that you
have to and bring in somebody
new, and then you have
a year of them, two or
three years, or some of you
are sitting on four and five and six years
of somebody who's not
good enough to do the
thing you want.
These are very difficult tasks of a CEO.
You see me at meetings--Gary
what do you do?--
Meetings and travel around.
I CEO, (beep)!
Also, next, we have creative
friends, Vayner, through Gary,
this is how we're positioning,
has created friends
all over the world, and
we would like to use them
to create some content
that is more, you know,
what I would call obtainable luxury.
Let's start using that.
(office chatter)
- [Woman] Hi Gar.
- [Gary] Hello, everyone.
- [Man] What's up?
- Craft Brew Alliance, that's cool.
Is he a nice guy?
- He's great, he is awesome.
- What is Craft Brew Alliance?
- They're Kona Beer, so they took a bunch
of small breweries...
- Can you introduce me to them?
- Yeah.
- I am on a mission to turn
my family's liquor store
into the leading craft
beer retailer in America,
and I want to start rounding
up all those relationships.
On this episode, the
wonderful Cy Wakeman is here.
Cy, you're on DailyV now.
- Okay.
- Officially.
- Awesome.
- Give me three words everybody
should be thinking about.
- Oh my gosh, more than three!
Stop believing everything you think.
Does that work?
- Yes.
- Okay, mwah.
- Love you, thanks for being on the show.
- Stop believing, believing is one word.
Stop believing in everything.
- [Crew] Everything, everything.
- You think.
Seven?
When I got asked three words, I nailed it.
(microphone noise)
Are you guys building
an agency or do you want
to build a media platform?
There's a place to play,
and I'm trying to figure out
where you guys want to go.
Or are you still debating it?
- So I'm happy to steal some of the air.
- I respect that, I'm debating 900 things.
- We obviously see the value in being able
to create our own content
and do that for our
brands and companies that we work with,
but we also recognize that there's a huge
social component that
we're still trying to
build out as well with the clients that we
bring in, but this platform
or this side of the
house, right...
- House.
- is solely focused on creating
content that's brand work
or creating original stories
or compelling stories
that we could tell and push out.
- Cool, so you guys know each other?
You said?
- Yeah, since college.
- Okay, and so the thing
that you're thinking about
now is you want to produce
original content around
you, how should I be thinking about...
What's my perspective?
I'm sure you guys have your perspective.
And what's the best, the
thing that you think maybe
I know even better than
your own subjectiveness
is the distribution of?
Okay
- 'Cause it's like what's
exciting from a storytelling
perspective was like, okay,
I'm not a big football person.
Well, the conduit to the story is here.
- [Gary] 100%.
- And if I could share
a story for a player,
and let folks know
what's inside the helmet,
using him as the conduit,
that's information
that ESPN doesn't get and HBO doesn't get.
- Yeah, I mean if your story,
listen, it's information.
- [Blonde Man] That's exciting to anyone.
- I think you know this,
they have versions of them
getting that, I think the bigger part is,
if you're a good storyteller,
you always have options.
I'll wait for that video.
- Yep.
- Love you, talk to you soon.
Right here is good.
- Can I ask you really
quick just before I bounce
out of here, I really came
here to New York just to
meet you, really.
It's funny, I was just
sitting in there waiting,
and I got the notification
on my phone from YouTube,
from your channel, saying
you were looking for
content creators, and
I'm like, I don't know,
well, it's kinda what I do.
(laughing)
- Hey I'm a content creator!
Let me get right to the punch line.
I've figured out that what I'm offering is
incredibly interesting, and game changing,
and that I believe that
there are tens of thousands
of people that can either
afford to or believe that
it's the right strategic
decision for them,
to come and work on this
team for $15 an hour
for two years and I don't take lightly
New York City's expensive.
I believe in my thesis.
I believe that you should
live with four people.
If you want...
I believe in, I'm just offering things.
I also know that some
people have rich parents,
there's a million ways.
But we're about to hire
a lot of people who can
do pre and post, film and
post, content for social,
and I'm gonna hire a lot of them.
So to be very blunt, if
you're yes to the first part,
well then you'd better send
them some content asap,
and give them some sense...
And by the way, we're not
looking for fire, we're
looking for nuances that
make us believe that we
can get them to fire.
It's the work ethic
that we're looking for.
We want somebody who's
excited about making
Snapchat content for 15
hours, somebody who's
excited about taking
that interview that you
just watched and chopping it up.
You know what we do.
- I really just wanted
to think about for myself
being like an entrepreneur
somewhere similar to this,
or if not here, where I
can just leverage the brand
association...
- My man, I have no idea
why you're standing in
my office right now, but your timing...
(laughing)
It's true, I don't.
I don't know, I don't
know why you're here.
But I can tell you that
timing is really fucking good.
Because if you literally
came here three months ago,
I'd be like, yeah,
definitely send an email,
like we're not thinking
about it the way we did
five minutes ago.
Now we're thinking about
it like I'm gonna find
15 of them asap, because
I'm gonna teach 'em here
and then they're gonna
be the foundation of the
next version of Vaynermedia.
But if you're interested,
you need to set--
as long as--I mean at some level...
I don't know what their barometer of like
giving you a yes and giving
Susan who's watching now,
'cause I'm gonna put this whole video out,
'cause this explains what
I'm up to more than anything,
a yes, but you should do
that immediately, because
I'm gonna put out this video
of you and I right now,
in addition to the
form, pretty soon, like,
I don't know, tomorrow.
So I highly recommend you move quickly.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
And so look I can literally
talk an entire book out
in one breath.
- [Man On Speakerphone]
Yes you can (laughing).
- But I can't write two
sentences together coherently.
So in January, when Crushing It comes out,
it will be my fifth New York
Times best selling book.
I find that laughable
for a man who can't write
three sentences together.
It's because I created
infrastructure in Stephanie Lamb,
my ghost writer, and I'm
betting on my strengths
of video and talking, gift of gab.
I'm the number one
followed person on Medium.
I can't write.
I have Colin Campbell, who's
a beast in transcribing me.
He listens to...
He'll listen...
I'm filming this right now.
He'll pitch me, hey, let's
do betting on your strengths.
He'll transcribe everything
here, but he'll be missing
some stuff.
He'll call me and interview me.
- Really it's just mindset.
So if you think failure is mental?
- I think people are,
I think people grew up
in an environment, it's nature/nurture.
You are scared and you
have allowed failure
to be on the offense,
and I don't want to spend
any time in this article
on whether you were
born with it or you were
conditioned to be that way
based on the way your
parents parented you,
or the environment you were in.
I just want you to recognize that truth
and start the process
of putting all your time
and energy in figuring out
how to go backwards on that.
- [Man On Speakerphone] Got it okay,
lean into your strengths, got it.
- Good content day.
What up?
It's finally official, I
had to triple confirm it,
so I wasn't promoting it.
October 9th, Columbus
Day Monday, in New Jersey
at the West Orange Manor,
we have the wine library
charity event where we
donate all the proceeds
to I think the Crohn's
and Colitis Foundation,
obviously with AJ.
And I'm doing something
super cool, which is a
high end wine tasting and Q&A.
I just wanted to make a quick
video about the $500 ticket
in this email that you saw,
business and wine Q&A session.
This event is going to be
part of the super tasting
that you see.
Super tasting is something
we started 2001, right?
16 years ago.
If you are in the tri-state
area, or if you've ever
wanted to come and really
chop it up with me,
this is the plane ticket you need to buy.
Columbus Day Monday, New Jersey.
There's a limit of 40 or
so tickets for this $500
business and wine high end tasting.
I love you back.
Seth, Seth? Our Seth? Seth!
That's you?
Seth, you're supposed to be fucking...
Seth, you need to be working here.
No wonder my podcast is slipping
down the ranks.
Seth is like on Instagram Live.
Seth, what do you have
to say for yourself here?
- I got your notifications on.
- Are you excited about the super tasting?
Are you gonna go?
- I would love to go.
- Good, sold one.
All right, super tasting.
Check it, see ya'.
♫ Reachin' out for me.
- Hey Allison.
- Hi, how are you?
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, how are things?
- Very, very good.
- You know the whole 60
second, you know the whole
60 second club thing?
60 second club is all of
the next year on Instagram,
I'm gonna reward my hardcore
community for everybody
who likes an Instagram
post and leaves a comment
in the first minute of an Instagram post.
So that's why you gotta
turn on notifications
so you see it comes in.
A bunch of you are in
that and you got your
notifications on on Instagram,
which I continue to recommend you do.
Well, I give tshirts and books out,
but sometimes I give the
ultimate prize, which is
access to me, so this was
a 30 minute win, right?
- Yes.
- Where're you from?
- I'm from Florida, but I live in Atlanta.
- You know what you need to do, right?
You need to try as many
things as fucking possible.
- That's what I'm trying to do right now.
- But I mean for real, like you need to to
and hula dance.
You need to go try to
take pizza making classes.
You need to travel with scrap up money,
and like, everybody can do everything,
with very little money.
Everybody thinks you need money.
Barter.
Tyler has skills in making videos, right?
- [Winner] Yeah.
- He could literally do
anything he wants in the world.
You want to do something, barter.
Barter is a real trick.
If you've got something,
like, how do you think
shit went down before money?
- [Winner] That's true.
- Like, you have meat,
'cause you have a cow,
and I have fucking fruit
'cause I have a tree.
You have clothes 'cause
you can fucking sew
and I've got fucking
paint 'cause I figured out
how to make it, like I
don't know, like barter.
I would type in your location on Instagram
every night.
Put in the town.
Actually, let's do it together.
Pull out your phone.
- [Winner] Let's do it right now.
- Right now, put it into
places, and literally
biz develop my way into new experiences.
Like who's this person took
these caterpillar pictures?
He's a visual art and paint maker.
He took these incredible,
like, right, you see it?
- [Winner] Yes.
- You should just DM him.
Like first of all you
have to think there as rad
as I do, and be like, hey
man, that's super rad.
Next thing you know
he's teaching you how to
fucking paint caterpillars.
Like that's life.
Just open up your world.
Somebody's going to watch
this video or listen to
this podcast, email me
in 21 years and be like
I became a world, world-famous jelly maker
because I watched you interview some girl
who was a college student,
you told me the DM move,
I fucking did it 'cause
I was like fuck it,
I DM'd this person, he
taught me how to make jelly,
and it ended up being the
thing that I was best at
in the world.
That's what I thought.
- [Woman] She's amazing.
♫ Reachin' out for me
- You gonna film here?
These meetings?
Nah.
All right guys,
I'm trying to drink these
shakes 'cause I try not to eat.
Anyway, good day.
Lot of content.
Got an HR meeting now with some leaders.
Got a couple more senior
media internal meetings,
so three or four internal
meetings now, get home,
off to Seattle tomorrow.
See ya'.
♫ It won't leave you alone
♫ Oooh
- I feel like we should
do something cool here,
where Pure wow starts,
isn't that place where you
can stand in four states in one spot?